now on to our next Story the evening and
I'm afraid to say it's certainly um not
upbeat in anyway but we're gonna have an
interesting discussion about this
Manchester United Mason Greenwood that
player they've agreed to part ways
following an internal investigation by
the club let's remind you what happened
the now 22 year old was arrested and
charged for attempted rape and assault
in January last year the striker later
had the charges against him dropped
after a key witness withdrew their
support and new material came to light
United who launched their own
investigation said today that their
inquiries have now ended United
spokesperson saying all those involved
including Mason recognize the
difficulties with him recommencing his
career at Manchester United it has
therefore been mutually agreed that it
would be most appropriate for him to do
so away from Old Trafford and we will
now work with Mason to achieve that
outcome that was the statement from the
club I am joined now to discuss more of
this by Professor Ellis Cashmore
academic and author of the book studying
football and by the UK's first female
FIFA licensed football agent Rachel
Anderson the two of you great to have
you to speak about this hello good
evening and I you know I'd like to make
clear that obviously the allegations at
the heart of this are sensitive they
involve young people
um not here to make a moral judgment
against either party those were the
facts of what's happened that we just
reminded people of the allegations
um and then the fact that they were
dropped and the negotiations that
happened since then and Greenwood hasn't
been playing we've been wondering what's
going to happen to him what is
interesting to talk to you both about is
the fact that the club at this point has
had to almost uh step in and play judge
and jury about what to do with mason
Greenwood's future whether to keep him
on or not uh I will come to you first
Rachel and just ask you very simply have
they made the right call here
I've made the right call for Man United
for sure because they need
well they have an asset that they would
like to get some of their money back for
and um he's a very valuable asset I mean
he's a great player there's no denying
that
but he just wouldn't be able to play
here that's for sure so they need to try
and Loan him out and try and get some
money for him hopefully with a potential
sale to a country where um he'll be
happy and everyone else will be happy
okay there's a lot I want to ask you um
about your comments but I also just want
to get across to Professor Ellis
Cashmore and get your simple answer that
have the club made the right decision
no poor decision going
because I think they're shaking the
responsibility uh United they're a club
as such I think they should uh at least
give this guy a chance to rehabilitate
himself uh everybody's capable of making
a mistake particularly in their youth I
have I'm sure most of our viewers have
at some point in their lives and so they
should be given a second chance United
are denying this guy there
I mean I'll come back to you Rachel you
were listening to that just I hope you
could hear what Professor Ellis Cashmore
was saying
allow you to respond go on
well
it's not man United's job to
rehabilitate somebody how can you why
would you need to rehabilitate somebody
if they haven't done anything wrong
it is the football club's responsibility
to rehabilitate sport historically has
been one of those experiences where
people from all walks of life who have
made mistakes sometimes being in trouble
with the law sometimes have done
prisoners at the time they go to Sport
and they find themselves in sport they
find themselves some positive direction
some Pursuit uh and they're usually
constraint and I shouldn't say usually
but a great many times they can
straighten themselves out so I think
football does have a sense of
responsibility in that sense
so that I can understand where the
professor's coming from do you have
daughters or
do you have daughters or sisters or
anything
you have no children okay
because there are certain things that um
if if a child misbehaves then you'll
give them another chance but when
something is as serious as this how many
children yeah you're saying it's serious
Rachel but all charges have been dropped
this is what we all know we're not silly
we all know that yeah so you're not
silly legally the man is free and clear
he has done nothing wrong in the eyes of
the law so just to jump into it he's
he's not been cleared from the point of
view of having been tried on those
allegations the allegations were
withdrawn by a key witness
other material came forward go on the
outcome is is the same here's a free man
let's let's listen to Mason Greenwood's
statement in Fuller he said I want to
start by saying I understand people will
judge me because of what they've seen
and heard on social media and I know
people will think the worst I was
brought up to no violence or abuse is
wrong I did not do the things I was
accused of have I fully accept I made
mistakes I'd take my shared
responsibility of the situations which
led to the social media post I'm
learning to understand my
responsibilities to set a good example
as a professional footballer then he
goes on to talk about the decision made
with the club like I said really complex
set of allegations here very complicated
we have to reiterate the charges were
withdrawn dropped
um they're having this Rosanna is that
this guy is not going to find another
club certainly not in England probably
not in Europe nor even in Saudi uh the
guy has been put out to dry and may not
no longer have any kind of professional
career go ahead at Rachel because that
you brought it up in your first answer
that he would find it hard to find work
in this in this country but you think he
couldn't find work overseas of course I
mean there's a matter of the unnatural
fact is that most clubs will do a deal
with the devil and it's just
he is an amazing player and any club
that gets him as a player will get a
good deal it's just about the club's
sponsors they may not be so keen on him
what's the club what's man united
supposed to do they're just supposed to
what just let him sit on the sidelines
you have no idea Rachel for all we know
I thought that would be how difficult
that would be for the player to never
play all his life as short as it is
he is very skilled and he will want to
play whether it's at man united or
whether it's another club he will want
to play I know they want to play but how
many clubs are willing to take the rest
also talk about let's also talk about
the reason why one of the key reasons
likely why they couldn't retain it which
was fans uh they've been women they've
been women fans outside the club who've
been protesting outside and saying they
don't they want Manu to take this
seriously as they will at every other
club
there's been a differentiation some are
saying between the the match day fans
and what they're saying in the stadium
and then versus the online fans who are
probably quicker to make judgment
because obviously we know being behind a
keyboard allows you to say things a lot
more quickly so so in terms of the
pressure that the club is facing how has
that influence things Rachel
well they have an industry that they
have to they have to protect it you know
they have
um their sponsors Etc and
the sponsors are a factor in the next
sorry go on Ellen sorry the responses
are a factor in the next you reckon now
I've always reckoned that sponsors are
in the mix I didn't say they were maybe
Adidas had something I just think that
you you're you're
that the fact that you're saying that
man united should keep him
to rehabilitate him I've never heard
anything so ridiculous to be honest um
Professor I also want to Professor let
me just remind Rachel uh uh and I think
she may recall they are accounting art
incident I mean it was a long time ago
27 years or what whatever uh this is a
guy that was convicted and sentenced to
jail time he didn't serve it initially
because he appealed it but Manchester
United stood by Cantona in fact they
pursued him they they went cap in hand
to ask him to come back
convicted
it's the point that I know there have
been previous examples of Sportsmen and
footballers who have broken rules and
been you know charged and convicted even
and have remover clubs is this not a
sign of the times changing it is yeah it
precisely right the times are changing
very yeah and in fact they they've
changed
uh colossally since the metoo movement
again momentum which is a great thing of
course but it is symptomatic of the
world in which we live that no one is
prepared to stand by someone who is in
the eyes of the law Innocent but has the
stigma attached to him uh or her as the
case may be charges and this is a
problem with the childish withdrawal or
the case didn't continue because a
witness withdrew
than me will be able to tell me the tiny
percentage of cape rate cases or sexual
assault actually go to trial because
invariably it's if it's a sexual assault
against a female it's the female that
withdraws because of the pressure and
the
terrible situation I mean there are
thousands of rapes unfortunately every
year of which a tiny tiny percentage
goes to court let alone get convicted
Rachel we do also have to clarify of
course that the charges were withdrawn
and dropped but here we go hearing your
point um loud and clear both of you we
have to end things there really
appreciate it though it's been
fascinating thanks so much
thank you